tratar de eso para ustedes en noches
para mí aquí en Sao Paulo el día de hoy
pues le podría decir que fue un buen día
para el presidente electo Lula da Silva
almorzó con el presidente argentino
Alberto Fernández que llegó hasta aquí a
Sao Paulo a un hotel para conversar con
él y además pues célula ya recibió el
respaldo o el saludo de presidente de
todo el mundo lo llamaron mandatarios
desde Francia o de España de Portugal
también de Turquía de Chile de Cuba
etcétera Pero entre todas estas llamadas
destaca una y es la del presidente de
los Estados Unidos soy Joe biden ellos
tuvieron una conversación que duró unos
20 minutos y en ese tiempo pues hablaron
de diversos temas como cooperación y
también como medio ambiente justamente
sobre medio ambiente Lula da Silva ya
expresó el día de hoy que le interesaría
asistir a las 27 que se realizan los
primeros días de noviembre ahora él
tiene la invitación pero va a depender
de temas logísticos si puede asistir Y
por supuesto de la transición con el
gobierno saliente en otros temas el gran
titular del día de hoy no llegó a
suceder y era esa esperada pronunciación
es de bolsonaro se pronunciamiento que
no se dio desde Brasilia Pese a que se
pensaba que hoy podía hablar los
periodistas fueron expulsados de plan
alto y se aseguró que no iba a haber
declaraciones el que sí habló fue su
hijo Flavio que además es diputado y que
fue su coordinador de campaña en un
mensaje de Twitter en el que por un lado
pues agradeció a los votantes de
bolsonaro por haberle dado a su padre la
mayor votación en la historia desde que
está en cargos públicos y por otro lado
en un mensaje bastante confuso pues se
dijo que no van a abandonar a Brasil que
no van a dejar este proyecto
bolsonarista en el país
finalmente usted hablaba también es de
los bloqueos de camioneros efectivamente
unos 20 estados tienen estos bloqueos lo
que se sabe es que la policía está en
negociaciones para que se levanten pero
no hay una orden gubernamental desde que
sean efectivamente retirados Los
camioneros en este momento